Red Dead Redemption 2 is filled with
crazy details like the first time I
kicked a chicken
I won't lie
I definitely did it more than once
what is Red Dead Redemption 2 holy crap
whoa question the prequel and sequel
simultaneously in a way to Red Dead
Redemption the sequel to one of my
favorite games of all time a massive
epic open world Western game it is
basically a cowboy Fantasy game ultimate
Cowboy simulator with a really cool
story that's a very boring description
of it really it is one of the most
ridiculously ambitious video games that
anyone has ever taken the pains to
create a monstrous gigantic huge Mungus
amazing immersive groundbreaking vitally
important artistic expression I think
it's just such a miracle that this game
even exists it was a toy
that is also art
[Music]
my first memory of Red Dead Redemption 2
and actually playing the game is that
opening like Fade Out of you just
trudging through the snow the opening
hour of Red Dead Redemption 2 for me was
honestly a slog
um at first I thought that a lot of the
criticisms I'd seen about the game were
correct the game starts slow as hell
like really slow like almost like jrpg
slow it's frustrating to trudge through
that snow the wind in your face the fact
that you can't see anything it feels
oppressive the amount of times I've
replayed the game and I have to go like
oh God damn this this stupid open snow
tutorial thing but the first time I
played it it sets the tone so perfectly
you're already on your back foot this
starts with you in the middle of a
situation A dire situation in which you
are just trudging in snow with a group
of people you don't know yet but you
know you're in it together and it took
its own sweet time I appreciated that
and while it's not an exciting opening
it does a Pitch Perfect way of painting
the scene even if you think that you're
bored by it or something there will be
something in that section that you're
meant to experience as a player and the
game would fundamentally not be the same
thing had you not gone through that
so we're getting out of this hell hole
we're gonna try coming out of the snowy
area from the intro of the game and into
Valentine for me was when I it just that
was when I fell in love with Red Dead
Redemption 2. it makes that feeling of
taking off your big coat and getting on
your horse and riding and seeing the Sun
and all the animals in the grass and the
water and all the stuff all the more
rewarding that was straight up like
getting out of the jail dungeon thing
from the beginning of Oblivion and
seeing the big verdant Green Hills in
front of you and being like Oh yeah it's
time for video game I love that moment
it's sort of as if the game has gone
okay now you understand what this game
is and how to play it let's come down
the mountain and find the spot outside
of Valentine here comes the world snow
is getting the thinner world's getting
warmer yeah
I'm gonna love this it's almost
difficult to like match that feeling of
awe when entering a world where you
realize everything you see you can go to
you can touch the draw distance holy
looking out into the distance I mean
it's every backdrop is a painting the
actual setting of it makes you feel
things in a way that a lot of other
video games don't I've described it as a
world not a playground whereas I think
GTA games are like playgrounds but when
you play Red Dead Redemption 2 you are
soaking up this world and that really
set the stage for the adventure I would
say and then it's like okay now you have
another chance and so that's what you
should treat this as
let's go boy
you did really feel like you were camped
way outside of town and then anytime you
had to go do something you had to like
all right rustle up your horse and go
into town it almost felt like a real
life commute Valentine is a small town
it's just kind of this quintessential
classic western town Valentine is the
coolest Town ever because it is like an
old cowboy saloon in town that I could
imagine going into back in the day and I
love being there I I didn't want to
leave I think in just in terms of how
long I spent there I think my favorite
town is strawberry strawberry uh if you
wanna in the kind of American pollens I
like how it feels a little more closed
off than the other towns it feels a
little bit more isolated it made the
mission with Micah so much more
difficult where he just kind of shoots
through the the town and the entire time
I'm just like why are we doing this
Arthur please please this town is nice
we don't want to ruin it when I was
trying to do things like mess around and
see how wanted I could get or kind of
become a little bit more Infamous I
would sort of terrorize the town of
strawberry which I don't feel great
about but there was also the post not
that far away that I could pay off my
bounty my favorite town is definitely
sandini to just suddenly find yourself
walking down dense city streets it
really actually felt like you were a
cowboy for the first time like you know
growing up in the wilderness wandering
into a city and it is crowded with many
different types of culture it's
overwhelmingly large and the difference
of you know seeing all of these light
bulbs everywhere you know it really
makes them stand out it makes it feel
like living in this city or living out
of the range or two completely different
Lifestyles you go from like the dirt of
the rest of the world to sandini and
you're like
I better behave myself here I say that I
didn't role play but I definitely feel
like I changed the outfit that Arthur
was wearing because I really wanted to
fit in this is a bit much ain't it a
coach
we can't bring it up there aren't horses
like a bunch of countrified yokos it was
very common for me to pack up my horse
with horse whatever I could find and
going long hunting trips on those narrow
Mountain Trails I wasn't up there for
the in-game encounters so much as I was
up there to search around and
just see where that stream LED I'd be
remiss if I didn't mention my horse who
I did develop a little too close
relationship with the so it would
disdain and the anger that I felt
towards any single person that hurt my
horses was
I mean bordering on evil I'm just gonna
pamper you a little
more
I knew it was gonna be
a story of something being taken
you know and that's and that that's
rough that's really rough so the horse
was just seriously the cherry on top of
the tragedy Sunday a few [ __ ]
you played Shadow of the Colossus and
you know how to hurt me what has stuck
with me for
four years now almost five years is the
story that's a group of people that were
not for Dutch and Micah I'm not entirely
sure it would have been a violent group
of human beings in general it's so nice
for uh Dutch to always have something to
Rally against whether it's you know the
lull or the beginning of the game it's
like the o'driscolls and the last thing
we need is to get bushwhacked by Como
Driscoll those damage riskels the Dango
durscals those darnold driscolls no damn
old riskels oh man that line will stick
with me forever I will always be
thinking damn old Driscoll's the
o'driscolls are uh a pain in the ass I
think they were good villains and it was
fun to get all wrapped up in that stuff
and uh you know the double crossing that
was happening between you know these
gangs and all the stuff that all the
internal drama that was happening in our
own gang I thought it was fun I always
think of the line from Dodge and Arthur
where they save Sadie Adler and they're
like
he ate them they turned her into a widow
animals you see that they have something
that they at least consider an ethical
standard that they operate under sure
they might do bad things but they're not
really out to individually hurt people
and that was what set them apart from
their driskels and for me that was like
the connecting thread that I needed was
having the old driskels being like okay
those are worse bad guys all right I can
deal with that so
spit at them every time
the train Heist for me was really cool
because it was Rockstar definitely like
cashing in on what they learned with uh
Grand Theft Auto 5. I feel like I'm in
an old western movie at this point doing
something that you'd see in one of those
films and it really puts you there here
we go
all the gameplay mechanics early on from
fighting to aiming to be able to
maneuver communicate with players
everything aligns in that moment and a
beautifully constructed narrow sequence
it's a huge like stamp of intent I think
from Rockstar to go this is the kind of
stuff you're going to be doing in this
game and it's gonna feel epic the fact
that you could go inside the interior of
the train and just look at everything
and open cupboards and do all that kind
of stuff I was like oh I'm gonna be I'm
gonna be in this game for a long time
when it's you know one thing to see a
really pretty environment there's a
bunch of trees and rocks and stuff but
when you like go into an area and
especially the change in lighting and
you know see the the texture of the
wallpaper and the you know the glow
coming off of those lamps even though my
expectations were high for this game and
the level of detail Rockstar usually
puts in I was impressed it's the first
moral decision you have in the game and
even though you are robbing the terrain
you get to decide are you a good Outlaw
are you kind of the Robin Hood Type
where you're not there to harm the
innocent or are you
you know the ugliest of the ugly and
you're gonna execute these people after
scaring the crap out of them and then
taking all their stuff I think my
favorite thing about that train Heist
though was getting a first impression of
how all of these different uh gang
members uh reacted to each other and how
they acted it gives you just a little
snippet of how these people work
together your Cowboys your criminals
you're trying to survive and in that
moment you get a you get that real hard
glimpse into who Arthur Morgan is about
them what do you think I don't know it's
up to you kill them leave them here take
them with you on the train just make
sure they don't send no folk after us
okay the first thing I think of when I
think of Red Dead Redemption 2 is it's
amazing protagonist Arthur Morgan feels
like
things have changed The Whole World's
changed
and they don't want folk like us no more
John Marston before I played Red Dead 2
was my favorite character in video games
but now I think it's Arthur Morgan I
think he's one of the greatest
characters in video games period uh he's
so nuanced as a character he he's so
complex and pretty much unlike any other
video game character we've seen before
and specifically something we haven't
really seen in westerns we get to see
old facets of his character you get to
understand his background a little bit
kind of like with his um his lost love
hello Arthur
Harry I love this question uh what is
Arthur's worst decision in Red Dead
Redemption 2 because there are a lot of
bad decisions Arthur's worst decision in
Red Dead 2 is sticking around there's a
world where you can see an Arthur Morgan
it's kind of like he's out there like 10
years later with a dad bought like two
kids and he's you know kind of doing his
thing in like the General Store in San
Francisco and he's doing all right
you know he probably misses the the
action a little bit but he's okay his
struggle in Red Dead 2 kind of
represents the struggle of a lot of you
know criminals of that era of you know
like when do I pack it up and and when
do you know uh I you know face that I
have made it as far as I'm probably
gonna make it following Dash's decisions
in roads I think because that's where
Arthur starts to realize just how in the
wrong Dutch is but he doesn't follow
through and so I think the worst
decision is ultimately the fact that he
stuck around with Dutch you just you're
like come on Arthur come on snap out of
it wake up have some goddamn Faith Dutch
is what you need in this he's the head
of the gang he it is it is his gang it's
him you know
trying
to do the best that he can for these
people in certain circumstances like
John and Arthur but he's brought up
since they were kids you see he's this
very well read guy maybe too well read
is he a grifter is he somebody just
trying to bring a community along and
keep people fed and keep people going
like it's very gray he's such a
believable layered intricate character
you you can't help but feel bad for him
when things start to go south you want
things to work out but you know they
can't and I think that makes his story
so much more heartbreaking I was gonna
say you're like a son to me
but you're more than that there's a
complexity there with Arthur being
grateful but Arthur also being fed up
with some of Duchess Shenanigans he
wants the best initially but he just
starts to really keep on going off the
rails and it's just another thing
another thing gets worse another thing
he's not succeeding that they never pull
anything off
it's just deep hopes and deep hopes
driven farther and farther to
exploration somebody becoming more and
more violent and doing things they
probably wouldn't have done six months
before the more it goes on the more you
actually hate yourself for going along
with it and not maybe speaking up sooner
but obviously Arthur you have to go
along with Arthur until he speaks up you
can't do anything about it and then he
has this mental collapse over you know
like a 50 plus hour story you can see
Dutch unravel and it obviously
culminates in in Tahiti I think that is
a important moment in the game where
Arthur really understands the gravity of
the decisions Dutch is making
much
what was that horrible old Chrome but
you killed her she was gonna betray us
Arthur couldn't you tell no well I got
some Spanish she was you keep killing
folk Dutch
I am just trying to make sure that some
of us survive Arthur Arthur bewildered
it's just like why what like what have
you what have you become what Have We
Become that we're killing old ladies I
remember like feeling like the Tahiti
section felt a little bit out of place
until I got there and then I was like oh
okay no we needed this whole section
just for this character moment I'm I'm
fine with Tahiti most
bad men break more bad as time passes
where Arthur's story is that of
redemption hence Red Dead Redemption
Dutch is interesting that he's the
reverse and a lot of times stories are
only as good as the antagonist so uh
he's just really completes the game I
know human beings art
you're gonna strangle me next
I think Arthur's worst decision
in Red Dead 2.
is not shooting Mica any chance that he
got we really should get out of here
like I said I need to see something
I had something to mine
my guns
Michael's a douchebag I mean he's a rat
oh my God Mike has such a little worm
I kept thinking like there's got to be
more to Micah there's got to be some
sort of twist ever tell Scott it's
Liberty Balance right I tried shooting
him every chance I got and the game
won't let you and that makes me very sad
what what what what the I've never felt
such dislike for a character before
Dutch said you was a a big shadow cast
by a tiny tree I don't even know what
that means I thought you was a tough boy
not one of those gentlemen it's so weird
but I think they did such a great job
with writing him they do such a good job
of selling just how like punchable he is
the thing about Micah is that you're
supposed to hate him right away and boy
did I hate him I've heard the actor who
plays him describe him as like coming
out of the swamp and you just feel that
grossness emitting off of him for Micah
I get the impression that it's not the
killing that feels so good as the
wounding they're all villains you know
this is a whole cast full of nasty
people and so like obviously some of
your you know your biggest hurdles that
you have to get over are going to be
just a little nastier than you I catch
myself thinking things about Micah now
and again and then going like I didn't
know I had that in me I think my
favorite moment in Red Dead Redemption 2
has to be the Micah fight
it is such an epic Monumental moment
when you as a character when Arthur
Morgan is on the verge of his life he is
going to die at the end of this fight
I'm getting emotional talking about it
that's hard not for any human being to
relate
to a fight that takes place on a literal
Mountain at the peak of this moment it's
beautiful symbolism it's absolutely
remarkable it is easily my favorite
scene in that entire game
I miss Arthur in such a visceral way
that's that I've never felt about
anything before film TV show anything I
miss Arthur so much that I wish I could
forget him I wish I could Eternal
Sunshine and Spotless Mind Arthur out of
my head Knox could so I could replay it
I wouldn't replay it because I don't
want to have to feel this loss I mean
clearly his worst decision really going
on that mission where you have to get
the money back that's owed and that's
how he gets his disease that's how he
gets tuberculosis you borrowed money
from my business partner hash Strauss
you owe him you took the money he wants
it back what's not to understand
obviously you can't see it coming but he
definitely paid for it it's a haunting
experience because I mean it happens
really early in the game and you don't
know about it for quite a while there
was a few times where he coughs and uh
that happens throughout many
conversations early in the game but it's
done in such a way because the game is
so
natural and off the coffin so well acted
that it could be excused as just acting
you're just like you're in the old west
you're in the dry land you cough there
was like a cough there's literally just
like one moment uh where and I don't
even think it was in a cutscene I think
it was actually controlling him at the
time and he just kind of coughed under
his breath and I was like oh no in the
reveal it was kind of like this
like holy sh they really are doing this
they're really positioning you to play a
character who is dying
what is it
it's not good news I guess that
you got tuberculosis
I'm really sorry for you son it's a hell
of a thing I remember swearing I
remember going oh no come on if you know
anything about tuberculosis during that
time there's there wasn't a cure they
time it to a point in the game where I
actually give a crap I know Arthur well
enough now to know that no I don't want
you to die and watching him deteriorate
and watching him lose weight in game
watching his face turn red is
it it's heartbreaking I was crying and
like three in the morning when I
finished that part of the game I was
like oh it's like almost like I went
through the stages of grief I went
through actual genuine denial
that he had it or maybe there was a way
to save him and maybe there's a way to
help him and uh just see him constantly
get worse and worse in that acceptance
of it was just gut-wrenching and then
all of a sudden I was like oh my God
this is gonna die like he's gonna die
and there's he's gonna die of TB and
it's gonna be nothing I can do about it
you just kind of see the wheels start
turning in his decisions and his
conversations with characters as the
game goes on and him really processing
his illness
I'm afraid
it's really the story about a man coming
to terms with his death and trying to do
right by other people because of it
at least the way my game ended my Arthur
left a really good path for John Marston
and and he ended things he ended things
the right way which I I haven't
whole epilogue felt like a love letter
to fans of Red Dead Redemption 1.
discovering that
sixty percent seventy percent of the map
from Red Dead one was in the game I
think armadillo still definitely does
have a huge place in my hop the part of
the game where you decide to play house
with John I I just adore it I'm just
like I'm building a happy house I'm
building a happy house it's fun it's fun
building the house my friends
I love it I love that moment I mean
everybody that's in this video has to
talk about that Lenny sequence getting
drunk with Lenny is probably one of
those moments that I will never forget
just because of how funny it is just one
or two right often of course just a
drink no big drum
oh
I think that's one of the best like
drunk Story game simulations ever put in
video games and just the way that it
kind of flashes and it's the situation
has escalated it escalated oh my God
yeah shut your mouth mister
[Music]
this wonderful memeified joyous bonding
experience the celebration of human
debauchery and friendship this one was
just to me the most hilarious where
Arthur starts seeing every character in
the bar is Lenny the button for Lenny is
like it changes and the text is
different and it's like spelled wrong
see a couple going at it obviously
they're both Lenny I even did a spoof of
it in my own video that I made where
there's like a million these right Dave
yeah that's right yeah that's just crazy
my favorite side quest there's a lot of
like weird creepy stuff in this game the
weird house
with the weird family uh is probably
definitely up there oh oh thank God
hunting down that serial killer or
finding the serial killers Clues I don't
know what you did
to deserve this suddenly then I'm on the
case I'm looking for a serial killer
finding the the UFO in the cabin at
night
as I run outside and they may just snap
a picture of it just as it's zooming
back up into the sky
is looking for Gavin is also a great
moment where he just kind of pops up
everywhere and he's looking for Gavin
and I don't think he's ever gonna find
his Gavin has anyone seen
called Gavin have you seen Gavin
you still haven't found him
the game does a really good job of
getting to care about Jack Marston and
you see him as a kid and you kind of you
become protective of him as he's really
the only kid in the camp there's that
mission where uh you take him fishing is
Arthur so when he gets taken and it
becomes you know the whole the whole
Camp sort of rallies together when that
mission happens when Jack is stolen and
you and the Gang are going up to the
plantation is that Silverado right there
toward the end suddenly you're in a line
of you don't even realize it and you're
all lined up on your horses and you come
over that Hill it's dark out you see
everyone's silhouette I I got chills the
shot
of Arthur Morgan and your gang lined up
looking at the plantation house and that
silhouette of your shadows being casted
behind you into your into your lens is
ingrained in my mind forever it's
remarkable it's a painting because by
that point in the game you have grown
such a fond connection and bond with all
the characters that it's like oh they
done [ __ ] up that's like that's all I
could feel is like I got my boys with me
I cannot believe they've done that you
mess with the wrong people you really
feel that in that moment it's very
interesting when a game can get you on
the side of the characters of like I
want revenge you feel a part of the gang
right you just feel you feel loyalty to
it you think about where Southern
Mansions come from right who doesn't
want to watch one burn down
and there's that shot of the entire gang
walking forward you can hear the music
playing there's fires and it is so
[ __ ] cool
the legacy of Red Dead Redemption 2 is
is going to be a fascinating one the
position rock star once again as
absolute pioneers and not just AAA
gaming but visual storytelling I like to
think the legacy of Red Dead Redemption
2 is elevating storytelling and games
and characters and games specifically I
really do believe that it is a American
classic story I had almost That Metal
Gear Solid moment again where I was like
we could have stories like this in games
it's just a very powerful well-told
story and I didn't expect it to be as
brilliant as it is video game
storytelling can be some of the most
powerful storytelling out there I really
I really go to the mat for Red Dead too
it is just a damn good video game like
kind of plain and simple it kind of made
me hold open world games to a way higher
standard having an open world that was
full of stuff to do in instead of having
an open world that is you know has the
same three things to do Red Dead 2 is a
game that brought millions and millions
of people dozens and dozens of hours at
your age that's the legacies people had
a good time playing it red that turns
into is is the best game I've ever
played I actually created a show around
Red Dead Redemption 2 where I took
horseback riding lessons I'd always
wanted to ride horses this got me to
take horseback riding lessons shot a
hole like cowboy mini film essentially
because of it
um because I was so inspired by the game
it's still one of my favorite things
I've ever done so I just look back as
like it's the game that inspired me to
do something I love doing I mean we've
barely scratched the surface man Red
Dead Redemption 2 is a world and a place
to get lost in simply one of my favorite
interactive entertainment experiences of
all time to this day I even wore my
Arthur Morgan jacket
get lost in it go back in time where
your Clint Eastwood get up and feel like
a cowboy
I have a real soft spot
Sadie Adler Sadie stands out any second
that I got to spend with Sadie really
just you know like elevates that game so
much she brought something to that gang
that really no one else uh brought she
takes no
she gives I would [ __ ] kill for a red
dead DLC that lets you play as Charles
or Sadie and fill in the gaps of their
story